I absolutely love those little GoPro
cameras yeah love those GoPro cameras
people use me to shoot amazing footage
sports networks use them all the time
for things like we'll check it out
there's like surfing incredible footage
you get great snowboarding footage you
can get amazing skydiving footage with a
GoPro it's fascinating it's changed the
way we look at the world you're well I
just got a couple of GoPro cameras for
Christmas and I don't do any of that
extreme stuff yeah what I did instead is
I attached them to a few mundane things
around the studio it's something we call
complete waste of a GoPro tonight's
first complete waste of a GoPro camera
we attach one of the slide on la Bamba
strombone there it is right there let's
see if that looks exciting go ahead la
Bamba
[Music]
I put a GoPro at the bottom on my coffee
mug okay I think that's a complete waste
of a GoPro let's check it out right now
[Applause]
[Music]
we even attached a GoPro to Andy's sub
Sam with my act to sandwich the case you
paint my highly acidic saliva dissolves
the food before I can digest it
why don't you dip your sandwich into my
into my cup right
just try that I know you wanted me to he
can't
they didn't say that of rehearsal and I
hate you I think my the size of my
sandwich scared it
[Applause]
nicely done hmm